24 days after suffering a heart attack  Bernie Sanders was back on the  presidential campaign trail  the Vermont senator was in Iowa Friday  he says he feels better than ever after  undergoing heart surgery Sanders is  focusing his message in Iowa on his  fight against corporate greed  he tells CBS News he believes the  wealthiest Americans are addicted to  money and are willing to exploit the  working class to further enrich  themselves  we are situations where companies cut  back on the health care of their workers  or the wages of the workers in order to  give you know unbelievably large  compensation packages to their CEOs or  do stock buybacks which enrich their  stockholders at the expense of the  workers so greed for some of these  people has literally become a religion I  need more more more like a drug addict  Sanders also to game it has rivals for  the Democratic nomination saying he's  proud his campaign does not quote sit in  rich people's living rooms to raise  money